we're gonna move on to this severe
storms in the middle of the country are
now blamed for two fatalities flooding
is the biggest danger right now with
many areas underwater in Missouri
Oklahoma and Kansas flood warnings are
up across the region and a new round of
storms could sweep in tomorrow CBS this
morning lead national correspondent
David Begg know is in skya took Oklahoma
that's northwest of Tulsa David good
morning
well good morning I can't tell you how
many people have told us they've lived
here 20 30 and 40 years that they have
never seen this type of flooding this is
the business section of sky took as the
crow flies the bird Creek is about a
mile that direction
yesterday we told you Bird Creek went
from 6 feet to 36 feet in 24 hours the
Oklahoma Highway Patrol was performing
rescues yesterday and they let us go
along our house is flooded before but
not it's never gotten into my whole
house we met Terry Pittman and her dog
Apollo after they got out of a rescue
boat Terry says she had 8 feet of water
in her home and that's about three miles
from Bird Creek our house has three
levels when it floods it gets in the
first levels it was like a foot in the
third level today from above you can see
just how far the floodwater stretches
into rural communities the Oklahoma
Highway Patrol took us out on an airboat
as they were performing rescues 16
adults plus children and pets were
evacuated in the 3 hour time period that
we were there and that was just within a
half-mile radius in skya took neighbors
helped this family get out of their
flooded holes this is awesome these all
these sons of high schoolers I'm ENGLISH
little
this storm also spawned tornadoes across
the plains suspected twisters in
Oklahoma and Missouri damaged multiple
buildings yesterday one in Kansas ripped
apart this home had the family go to the
basement and as I watched I saw a
tornado spin up back in sky it took we
met volunteers from the event Fire
Department having dinner the assistant
fire chief told us as they were making
rescues their firehouse was being
overrun with water the entire town of
Eyvind flooded the assistant fire chief
told me he has a $28,000 a year budget
and he said I can't even afford to
replace what we lost in this flood as we
are on the air right now the town of
Weber Falls Oklahoma it's about an hour
from where we are is asking everybody to
evacuate there's roughly 600 people that
live in the town the water is expected
to rise there and they want people to
get out now more troubles than Oklahoma
David thank you